all right first movie of 2023 and I'm
not gonna posture I'm not gonna front I
was going into this movie like oh okay
great I rated PG-13 Blum House horror
film in January let's
do that with everything that comes with
that but
however
[Music]
so I'm a three again
what's up with replacing the letters
with numbers really messes with the
search algorithm no one's searching for
mathrigan they're all searching for
Megan whatever so Megan's a film about
this little girl who loses her parents
in a car accident and her aunt gets
custody of her and her aunt works at
this tech company and she's like hey
we've developed this AI companion doll
this AI friend yeah it's like my buddy
kid's sister y'all remember you don't
doesn't matter that meets AI there you
go now she has a friend and from there
it's pretty much the plot it's like this
movie is a remake of the Child's Play
remake that came out a couple years ago
however unlike in the case of Child's
Play where Brad duriff's voice is
inseparable from the character if you
don't have Brad Dura voicing Chucky you
don't really have the spirit of Child's
Play Megan is new Megan can be whatever
she wants and this movie was actually
really good at having the audience feel
about Megan how they should probably
feel about their phones always watching
always listening everyone in the room
should be terrified of that fact and
they actually played that up well and I
got to say if this is a movie where
you're like all right sweet little AI
doll robots gonna kill a lot of people
and that's gonna be fun this really
isn't that kind of movie maybe it's
because the movie's PG-13 I do feel like
the movie was probably if I found out
this movie was filmed to be rated R I
wouldn't be the least bit surprised
there are a couple of moments where you
read the lips of someone you're like
that that is not what they said they
probably said something that would bring
this a little closer to our couple
moments like that couple of audio edits
where you're like those feel like two
different sentences that have been
stitched together or someone cut a word
out but it's January we gotta get more
asses in the states so PG-13 let's cut
it back would not be shock if that were
the case however if that was the case
I'd love to see a director's cut if the
rated R cut that maybe might have been
filmed that long-winded tangent brings
me back around to my original point is
this movie really isn't the whole AI
doll kills a lot of people bloodbath
that you might think it is it ends up
happening at the end it is fun when it
happens but it's not the point of the
movie but that I feel is when this movie
was at its strongest it's when it starts
elevating its premise this movie he
actually has an incredible message to
its core about human connection the
dangers of using technology as a
parental crutch the emotional
developmental skills for a child to get
lost in that execution that's something
that's far scarier than AI killing
people that we may or may not have to
deal with in the year 20 50 something
because that's something that's very
real now I was actually really impressed
this film dealt with such heavy subject
matter you're actually pretty invested
with the emotional state of this child
and how Megan's actually bad for the kid
on an emotional level the kid thinks
Megan is great but kids would think that
cake and ice cream for every meal of the
day is great so there's that and the
last act happens and at times it is
silly I mean the movie actually is silly
I'm not just talking about the fact that
Megan stole my dance moves this movie
actually does have we'll say some tonal
conflict you just want to line up
everybody the cast members will be like
all right raise your hand who here
thinks they're in a comedy
who here thinks they're in a serious
horror film
who here thinks they're in an emotional
film about family and human connection
yep those are all those are all
different hands and something like that
doesn't have to feel like it's in three
movies just did in this one it just
didn't feel like it flowed smoothly also
I feel like this movie could have been
15 minutes shorter thereabouts but in
the end Megan I had a surprisingly good
time with I was getting ready man I was
like all right let's go to Megan let's
[ __ ] on a bad PG-13 hover wow
I actually enjoyed that for completely
different reasons than I thought I would
it wasn't the horror it wasn't the death
it wasn't any Slaughter you see some
frankenstitching from other films and
their premise but it's a testament that
you can do that you can borrow you can
actually have the premise of a movie
that came out a couple years ago but to
your core you can build something that
does feel unique I think if they play
their cards right this could become a
franchise I'd actually like to see a
Megan too what would the title of that
look like mithrigan too but this is the
last we saw of Megan the character I'd
really be bummed out in the end I
shockingly had a good time with this one
no alcohol required all right so Megan
first film of the year have you seen it
just came out doubt it but have you seen
it or been searching for this review did
you type in mathrigan or Megan tell me
how that search algorithm is working out
whatever you think comment below let me
know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see
that was a lot deep breath do it all at
once comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
[Music]